welcome the Batman I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Mike Bernard a our founder
we're back folks and we're here to talk
about Ghostbusters and then that goes
Buster's that's what Ghostbusters did
you see umm yes
smoking at Ray Parker jr. son the
Ghostbusters movie is out folks we're
about to come out and he said yes and
Mark and I saw it we did so we can talk
about it today yes we have feeling
they're not deep-seated feelings they're
not the feeling shared by too many
people on the internet it's been a weird
year for the Ghostbusters gang as we've
seen you know they turned it into a big
brouhaha men vs. women and socially so
stealing our heroes a lot of this going
on but I I saw an interview with Ivan
Reitman where he said I honestly don't
think it's as much like you it's women
I've read a lot of it and you know the
hate on line he was talking about and
he's like it's not so much that it's
women it's just this movie for whatever
reason is special to it's a core
audience and I think in my paraphrasing
and you know it was it would been you
anybody that wasn't the original crew so
his point was like yeah there's hate but
it's not as yeah we [ __ ] hate girls
as much as you know the media may be
painted not painted with that brush but
they were like let's just show the most
crazy [ __ ] you know misogynistic
texts and tweets rather and hook him and
believe me there's a [ __ ] ton of it out
there yeah but I also don't think it was
always pure like you girls like that's
just some of it was like don't mess with
the thing I love yes you know which in
one day kind of fair I suppose for some
except for the fact that like
Ghostbusters too messed with a thing you
love
is not a good movie and nobody brings
that one up with my father I'll call
sponsors like what about girls poster
like there's no shame guys made another
movie that was horrible so maybe it's
okay it can move on it can move into
other hands look everything gets remade
sooner or later you know I'm saying when
I was a kid and they made King Kong 19
let him climb the Trade Towers and [ __ ]
I was like oh my god I was amazing and
my father's like I saw this when I was a
little boy and yeah there was the black
and white version and stuff yeah like
when I wanted to I see one of my
favorite movies is the shitty Clash of
the Titans which I love to death yes and
then they remade it into a shittier
Clash of the Titans which I cannot stand
hahaha but it's like you know what
here's the thing I still have the old
one that's the that's the awesome secret
about this is that I think Raymond
Chandler used to have a quote somebody
interviewed him about like they're
making another movie of one of your book
they're ruining your books in the movie
it's like no they're not like the book
is fun it's right there on the Shelf
like I still have it like and nobody can
molest that thing and that's a man with
respect and I gallon more would invoke
that when talking about like Watchmen
are talking about League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen say no the book
is cool it's still right there Oh
cracking open every year and read from
hell because I like to smart your eyes
also a wizard but he has a bit of a
wizard ISM mmm the notion of
Ghostbusters being remade at all I think
is what made there's a good portion of
people out there that were just pissed
about that because there was never clear
right away as this as equal as this tied
into the universe somehow and then once
it became clear that it was a reboot
then people were like what and you know
for my money as a fan and I'm not like I
have no source in this game other than I
just like people taking me on flight of
fancy
I think the Ghostbusters concept [ __ ]
can go a lot of places and stuff and I
would like to watch more of them and you
know so I'm all for them and stuff but
I'm not like in here I'll tell you this
man my [ __ ] my Ghostbusters memory
seeing in the theater first day my dog
Louie shut up man we're talking about
ghostbusters
don't be afraid of no ghosts now shucks
involved ghostbusters but I've got
thoughts um when I first saw Ghostbuster
1984 two things happen that day one I
saw Ghostbusters two right after that I
went to Bennigan's for the first time
ever I had a mozzarella cheese stick
they just introduced them so have you
tried the new cheese sticks I was it was
the was the first time I'm sure they did
it elsewhere in the world this is the
first time [ __ ] Bennigan's was like
what is this I was so like what is dried
penis thing it looks like chicken but
she was like cheese so you know in a
world of things that like that's a big
part of my childhood man you know the
cheese was bigger be honest with you I
love ghostbusters don't get me wrong
because dr. Peter Venkman and honestly
if there's anybody that should be upset
by a Ghostbusters remake it should be me
on like I've now I just thought about
has a massive Ghostbusters fan [ __ ]
massive
I based every [ __ ] character that
I've written who's not this straight man
in the movies on Bill Murray
particularly as Peter Venkman also as
you know tripper and uh stripes and and
uh it was no trip or meatballs and
winger and stripes and stuff oh and Bill
Murray just in general but Peter Venkman
man was like Randall and Brody like I
don't get to those characters without
that performance specifically so and in
that movie like fired on all solders
kept in mind captured my imagination and
special effects the ghosts and [ __ ] and
was just hysterical so if anybody out
there like should have been like now not
my childhood because it was also tied to
mozzarella cheese Jack says well you're
growing that could have been me and I
didn't I mean maybe it's just like I'm
old enough to know like you know they
remake all these things it's fun and
it'll be a shitty Lethal Weapon TV show
next season is there yeah yeah with
Damon Wayans senior playing the the the
Murtaugh role really yeah I'm vocal and
people are are not I bet he's over there
that's weird
like what so that's all a long way of
saying like I and I'm sure I speak to
mark a little bit we
and really give a [ __ ] when they were
like we're [ __ ] remake it a time
we're putting in ladies but I personally
as ghostbusters Pham I would have liked
it more the movie and I'm not saying
it's ruined because they didn't do this
but as a fan of fanservice and and like
tying movie universes together I've got
two of them myself I would have been
like you know that's little dot dr.
Peter venkman's daughter right at least
one of them tied into the world man a
little bit that that but that would have
made you know doesn't change right like
how the movies going to be perceived by
like 90% of the poppy it's a little bit
of fanservice and there's nothing wrong
with a little bit of fanservice I mean
this is and this movie has a little bit
of fanservice is God like the bust of
Harold Ramis it's God I love that the
entire cast in it the surviving cast
members in it but I mean for me the
movie was funny but could have been
funnier it was scary
could have been scarier I would agree
with it you know it was here's it like
when you're making a comedy you all no
amount of money you throw it a comedy
makes it funnier and if at its core this
is a comedy then it could have been a
lot funnier it you can throw money and
make a thing scarier except for the fact
that most of the most scary movies are
super [ __ ] cheap yeah because effects
don't make something scary like it's all
about technique and ingenuity and
understanding suspend catch of sound
sure that yes much money law so it feels
like what they spent their money on was
a lot of CG in the last third of the
movie that doesn't make it funny or
scary and it just makes it big and this
is not a movie that despite the fact
that the first one names on the top of a
building with a John Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man
now be careful we go really this is
movie it doesn't let me to be big except
that it started but like scale is not
the solution to the problems this movie
has no the actresses are all good like
and when they're just like we're talking
they're just hanging around and being
funny there are moments in the movie
that we talked to her before about the
things that I laughed out loud at the
hardest were things that were not
remotely ghostbusters related you know I
mean it's in the movie of ghostbusters
so it's all ghostbusters late but not
like plot oriented or there's a ghost or
any of that it was just some [ __ ] they
would have said if they put those four
people in any move
right like the ad libbed kind of moments
and stuff kate mckinnon had most of it
kate mckinnon
owned the movie for me I'm obviously a
big fan of her work but her and [ __ ]
Thor Chris Hemsworth
it's going for what a discovery [ __ ]
Jason Mewes [ __ ] foreign Silent Bob
that guy's Dynabook easy for me his [ __ ]
they get let him do his accent no rock
his [ __ ] accent I saw him in the
trailers I was a guy it's just gonna be
like [ __ ] a lot of himbo comedy and
it was
yeah but artfully done he was [ __ ]
funny as [ __ ] and just really game yeah
you could tell he had never gone to do
this before and was more than happy to
make himself look like an [ __ ] yeah
and he goes for it
it was fun there that that was a he was
definitely fun part of the movie um I
love Kristen Wiig but then there's no
but she's great in the movie but they
didn't give her a [ __ ] ton to do some of
the [ __ ] she did do I really did like
though they gave her this more weird
OneNote to play of like I want to [ __ ]
him all the time like every scene she
saw [ __ ] Hendra if I am to her that
she was like make me Thor see I was kind
of half hoping that times worth would
get possessed and [ __ ] somebody it would
be like that the Donna mills Ackroyd
thing was like oh I'm gonna [ __ ] that
guy he's possessed now wants to [ __ ] me
I wanted Leslie Jones to be riding Chris
Hemsworth like a stallion this one more
drag that could've opened it a hundred
million over the weekend um yeah I
wasn't feeling good slap it that's it I
mean again it's funny movie you
obviously I feel you could take your
kids to it yeah I don't think remotely
alienating were scary for children's
stuff yeah um you know but and if it
would be called anything else none of
this [ __ ] backlash or outcry would
have ever happened and stuff but the
fact is when you split the word
ghostbusters on the movie whether you're
connected to the original or not is a
big shoes to fill
yes and at the end of the day it's only
about did they make a funny movie they
did make a funny movie could have been
like as funny as the heat or spy to Paul
fake movies define bike 5 there's a
Kevin Feige and Paul fine I think it's
fine both fine
both bike um to Fox 2
magnifying the bags a girl in a pizza
plans to though that dude has made
hysterically funny movies with some of
the same talent including bridesmaids
yes so it just felt like you know felt
like a lot of the lot was cut it felt
like hockey there's there's a decent man
on the floor and they're kind of always
in a comedy because you're overshooting
because you say a lot to add living to
but you know here's the thing about spy
and and the heat you're subverting
you're subverting what those movies are
about those moves are traditionally male
films in the buddy-cop movie the
gentleman spy movie and there's been
many of them and they're big on tons of
them like decade's worth of each of
those kinds of films so when you put a
woman in the lead of those movies or
women in the lead of those movies it
automatically has this foundation of
other and different and humor there is
not a vast catalog of dude Ghostbuster
movies to be lampooning I believe
there's two there's two one of them we
don't even discuss anymore so you're not
silly hated that much it's just not I
hate it because if not versus you're not
did me hi Statue of Liberty walking
through and they're all in the crown
uh-huh like there's moments of that
movie that are kind of great but then
the movie as a whole is just the movie
as a whole but you know what I really
just like about that movie is that Dana
had a baby with somebody else
ah that's betrayal of the grandest level
yeah there's no there was no such thing
as fanservice in the late 80s man they
were just nope yeah in real life that
wouldn't have happened yes
does that girl really [ __ ] that dude a
lot no twice maybe definitely not
getting married definitely not having
kids I remember being disappointed but
I've been like no no I was not as
disappointed as like when [ __ ] alien
three begins they look like the best
part of the movie and the last one is
dead she died in her sleep
like what [ __ ] Newt do you know Newt
is gonna be at Comic Con all of them are
gonna be a Comic Con
I'm dude we've seen the rest of them
newts been missing in action she died in
space and also I mean Paul Reiser is
gonna be there yeah we've seen he had
his own [ __ ] show he did but 40 years
ago
I ain't against Reiser but I'm
all pro carry hen man like this she's
been gone I know I'm I have expected
them to bring out a robot and they're
like her brain's been placed into this
are we gonna get to sit down and talk
with her at the con I [ __ ] hope so I
just want to talk to her but we're here
you Oh Jane Cameron I don't care what
you might have to suicide avatar thank
you sir greenie Weaver whatever the hell
your name is her I would definitely be
like where'd you go man where you been
like she was amazing in that movie yes
it's one of the greatest [ __ ]
childhood performs all time maybe she
just dropped the mic she's like what am
I gonna do Jews never gonna be better
than a cheese like I didn't really plan
to be a child actors they got this and
[ __ ] 100% and then just walked away
I'm gonna be schoolteacher or whatever
she does I'm that's what I'm honestly
man like [ __ ] they didn't even need
to do the aliens 30th anniversary it
just could have been like Newt and that
flew to packed the [ __ ] place anyway
boy have we get to that I only remember
Ghostbuster subversive yes like funny
stuff in the movie that came from people
that were in our heroes yeah like the
guy who was like you know doing the
[ __ ] multiple like he's like always
like oh no I got it she like but he was
genius man but that bit could have
played in any movie it's not very
Ghostbuster specific yeah like the the
thing about the first Ghostbusters the
OG Ghostbusters is that if you take away
all of the jokes it's still a legit
[ __ ] horror movie
it still works I took my ten year old
kid so he's frightened out of his mind
because he didn't get the joke so he's
he is afraid of ghosts
yes he doesn't like my ghost I'm not
afraid of no ghosts you know is it
without the funny to Levin that it's
actually legit thriller this movie
doesn't actually function that way like
it doesn't have that sort of
undercurrent of it's actually scary it's
never actually scary except the first
like the opening sequence in that
mansion which is just yeah listen jump
scares but it's like you see what
they're doing is it doesn't get under
your skin
right in any way the way like Dana's
apartment sort of rebelling against her
gets under your skin there's nothing
like that yeah and you know it was also
felt like a little bit was missing I'm
not like this ain't a detriment to the
film at all but like when they made
ghostbusters you know the dogs and
they you could feel him yeah rubble
stop-motion yeah and when they were
there in person she could touch him and
it was a big animatronic and [ __ ]
everything in this movie heals and by
the third Agee it is just a parade of
digital effect like literally literally
a parade and it you just lose some and I
love digital effects alive when they're
done well when they're they're deployed
with some skill and some deafness there
when it's just like a we're just
slathering affect John feels like the
ending of Batman V Superman where it's
like oh there's just three people in a
green screen yeah and all this [ __ ] got
added later on somebody [ __ ] looks cool
they do [ __ ] like Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man makes it of appearance
as well that that's I think will they'll
lose a bunch of the you know people that
like people who are like not like your
boogie mo childhood but like oh I love
Ghostbusters mm-hmm when they find out
that you know the spoilers spoilers
spoilers spoilers and that there's a
different giant thing to kill in the end
of this movie that's not Stay Puft right
there'll be a lot of like wow how did a
lot of dissention but I didn't here's
the one thing I found weird about the
finale felt like they were on the ground
floor the altar yeah like Ghostbusters
at the end they went up to just being on
top of a building has something you know
the top of the sea I don't know whatever
[ __ ] pyramid was open and all that [ __ ]
but this everything felt like variate
yeah and instead of going up they have
to go down there's the way this movie
works
that's right yeah oh my god see [ __ ]
you see everywhere um Leslie Jones funny
in the movie Melissa McCarthy's funny
they're all a critic they're all funny
in the movie I mean Kate McKinnon steals
whenever scene
she's a yes she is genius and she's just
going for it and it's not even like you
know she's saw people slacking off so
she's just open apart mm-hmm like and
you know on one level it's kind of a
garnish but she's yeah I mean you can't
even she doesn't really have a
counterpart in ghostbusters they really
don't do that it's not like Melissa
McCarthy is I mean if maybe Melissa
McCarthy is kind of like reg it's more
like Leslie Jones is the black
person who does not have any science
background yeah and so it's just the on
the streetwise New Yorker looking for a
job yeah it's like really Leslie Jones
couldn't have also been a scientist she
had to be the MTA worker who just love
eats books I don't know about this
science stuff it's literally live but I
know the streets I believe is the bottom
of line yeah yeah and so yeah yeah
that's the one
it's like you could have made kate
mckinnon the not scientist just crazy
[ __ ] brilliant yes like she's the
street kid yeah who's just I've been
bailing stuff on the street since I was
12
you're gonna give me a nuclear reactor
to build a gun out of this is amazing
I would have preferred and I know that I
read that they were gonna do this like
the Melissa McCarthy character was gonna
be more like Leslie Jones
she's very boisterous and loud the
non-scientists of the group I believe it
and then you know Paul the director was
like I've seen her do that hey let's
have her do this instead and then then
Leslie Jones winds up being my character
so it may be in the first draft that
would have been look like most McCarthy
was the non-scientists but I you know I
would have preferred Leslie McCourt
Leslie McCurry I would have preferred
Melissa McCarthy to be nah there's
nothing [ __ ] funnier in this world to
me than when Melissa McCarthy is loud
and boisterous and [ __ ] hurling
obscenities yes even on Sarah alive they
did this one sketch where she was like I
am junior congresswoman Sheila County or
something like that where she kept it
was a play on that one incident where a
New York one there was a guy
interviewing a politician then he left
and he was like well as you heard bah
blah blah he did smoke back in the plank
I throw you down the stairs like you
threaten the [ __ ] dude on camera so
they just sketch about it on SNL where
you know there's a Melissa McCarthy was
playing like this junior congressman and
Sheila Kelley and guys interviewing her
and she's like I don't agree with that
at all not to my knowledge this
interview is over and she storms out one
of the guys Turner goes that was a
junior congresswoman Sheila Kelley and
apparently she's not admitted to then
she comes back in and she's like hey
girl but I've been she better [ __ ]
mashido parishes I gotta push you out a
window she goes up for sure I'll push
you down the stairs like a little baby
in the carriage and Andy Garcia won't be
their Savior
like it's real in his [ __ ] face and
then she sees the camera and like you
know [ __ ] threatens the camera and
then like luckily somebody nearby was
also shooting the camera and then I'll
said she sees that camera use it and
it's a series of her [ __ ] going after
the cameras funny [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
but that that's just my preference I
like when she does that thing but I
could understand and perform I wanted to
be like well let me do something else
and she got funny stuff in the movie so
it's not like oh man what a mistake that
was for sure it's not like remember
neighbours yeah when John Belushi and
Dan Aykroyd switched parts the old
neighbors not the Seth Rogen maybe um
you know that it was Belushi was
supposed to be the obnoxious [ __ ]
neighbor and Aykroyd was a
straight-laced guy and then right before
they went they were like [ __ ] it we've
done that let's switch it and I always
wanted to see the other movie the other
movement probably would have been
fantastic that I kind of wanted yeah the
thing that you guys do really well
Ghostbusters the new Ghostbusters here
this is what I cheered on Hollywood
babble-on I shared here right before my
movie began there were the theater where
I was little girls dressed up at
Ghostbuster ovens dancing in the aisles
mmm that's the bank that's what it's
about just like when I was a kid and I
saw Ghostbusters I wasn't dancing and
Alex people be like Fat Boy sit down but
you know I left they're gone like
imitating the movie happy [ __ ] that I
saw played [ __ ] with my mozzarella
sticks like I was Slimer so uh you know
I I saw that and I was like that's
adorable you could see it you could be
it and those little girls are seeing it
yeah oh I could be Ghostbuster too so
that was really really sweet but the
thing I talked about on the podcast is
rod I'm baffled by is the poster tagline
is answer the call and I'm like what's
that yes Colin call the ghosts it's
hoping you remember the who you're gonna
call then why not just go who you're
gonna call
like why step away from that why not
just like answer the call means nothing
no nothing nobody calls anybody in this
movie happens with your bones
there's no supernatural call from the
other side there's no like the mayor
gone you've gotta save the city this is
my call it that tagline makes no sense
but they're also like not even reluctant
heroes so they're not they don't have to
heed the call to adventure they're down
it's just literally
you're gonna call is what it should have
been and I guess somebody was like you
gotta earn your paycheck this week
they're like answer the call sure good
enough slap it up there let her know
call in the family baffled all right so
it worth gone see look yes if you watch
this show you know obviously you go
figure on pulse pop culture
you gotta consume all this stuff can't
be part of the discussion if you haven't
seen it don't be one of those people
it's like [ __ ] this movie yes I know
what you say it no like no but look in
it you can hate it yeah but you have to
see it before you hate it yeah that's a
good point
yeah and I do you want to see it this
week no see we're never gonna see it now
sounds like talk [ __ ] about a thing you
know nothing about I'm very a grown yeah
I'm sorry
we should talking [ __ ] I don't know what
do you know how do you know you don't
know [ __ ] about [ __ ] you don't know
you're no dick peckerwood things are
getting very good lord we've lost mark
there it is folks the Ghostbusters 2016
I believe is what they're calling it man
pretty much go see it in a theater near
you answer the call and then let us know
who answers yeah [ __ ] whatever that
means there it is man for fat man I'm
Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark barnard
tune in next week same fat time same fat
channel SModcast calm in your ears or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith for your
eyes we just added that we did a thing
a man's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder